hi hugh hi elizabeth hello nice to see
you hello very nice to see you as well
uh so before i get into a new era which
was so funny and so emotional my
producer and i were sitting next to each
other we were both by the end like
crying but just loved every moment of it
um i wanted to go back to that first day
on set of this whole series uh could you
have ever imagined that you would still
be telling this story with fans wanting
more hue
no absolutely of course not no um
and i can remember i can remember the
very first read-through um at a uh in a
in a church hall in london um with this
enormous rectangular tables laid out and
um all of us relative strangers i mean
some of us knew each other some of us
didn't but and hearing over two days i
think it was we read all the first seven
episodes and i just remember sitting
back and just
really enjoying this story and wanting
to know what happened next and and
thinking uh thinking yeah this is
probably going to be it just this first
season and that's
the way of the world but it's it'll be a
fun story to tell and here we are as you
say so no one could have predicted it
but i'm delighted that we are where we
are
i love that listen do you remember the
first day on
set i remember that my first scenes were
i had a couple of days with just scenes
with maggie um
a
really energizing way to start to say
the lead
and i remember her making me laugh
um
uh and
i remember that she used to read a lot
and that at the end of
that little time i gave her a big stack
of books and um so that got us started
um
that's that's all i i remember
that is such a great memory that's
amazing uh okay so let's talk about a
new era um it was really fun seeing the
family go to france he was not like
shooting those scenes compared to
shooting in england
uh it was well it was different um
and uh for a while for a while there we
thought maybe it wasn't going to happen
at all because of the copied
restrictions but we were able to but the
um
but the challenge was really when we got
there that we had a quarantine for for a
week before we could start shooting so
there was the you know the hassle of
having to sit by a swimming pool for a
week um in the on the cote d'azur but um
once we got to the villa itself it was a
magical place to film it was hot it was
very hot and the crickets were noisy but
uh and the food went off pretty quick
but um but it was a magical setting and
uh looking out over that view and indeed
just you know being in those rooms was
uh was really quite special um
and uh
you know the story itself
relaxes and unfolds in a surprising way
when we're there so
you know it was a whole new texture to
the show while keeping its feet firmly
rooted in the in the spirit of downton
uh and of course them you know meanwhile
back at downton abbey uh a whole other
story is going on and i think uh i think
the pleasure of enjoying both story
lines um is evident on the screen it's
just uh it's a real tap rich tapestry
and and a real
uh just a great source of entertainment
it's no more than escapist fun and i
think i think that's what we've
delivered
absolutely so much of the comedy comes
from these movie stars coming to downton
and the family and especially the staff
getting so excited about their arrival
you know the last film the royals came
to visit so elizabeth who do you think
is the harder guest to host
royals or movie star
it turns out the movie stars were much
more
it's true i never part of it that way
how much no contest
yeah
was it fun you know obviously you're
filming this movie with modern
technology but to see the flip side
seeing how they used to film movies in
the late 20s
absolutely i mean one of the things that
struck me is that yes it was very crude
and hilarious to see the way that the
sound
guy
basically took over everything because
it was all about
the microphone suddenly but um i mean
things haven't really changed all that
much that wasn't
still filmmaking in a way
is
the same primitive
things that people figured out quite
early on you know
um
on those early days when they when they
figured out about um
cutting images together and i mean still
we do basically the same thing in the
way that other technologies have gone
through
into the stratosphere and changed
everything it's not quite true in
filmmaking although it's of course much
more sophisticated but i think i think
that's kind of interesting
yeah would you agree with elizabeth you
say things haven't changed much but
would you are you saying that you think
that you know movie stars
you know women movie stars are
annoying prima donnas is that what
you're saying
no
i'm saying technically
no purely technically okay just to
clarify
just to
clarify awesome thank you so much you
guys so nice getting to talk to you
congrats on the film it's so good
thank you for having us
you